CLIFF: All right,
so we're good to go.
Thank you all for
stopping by today.
It's our esteemed pleasure
to welcome Ava Roy to Google
as part of the Talks
at Google program.
She's the founding
director of something
called We Players, which had its
origins at Stanford University
and is now a prominent fixture
in life in the Bay Area.
Essentially, it takes the
ideas from Shakespeare,
making "all the world a stage,"
and delivering truth on that
and putting it into practice.
They do site-specific
performances and installations
throughout the
Bay Area, anything
from the story of the
"Odyssey on Angel Island"
to "Hamlet on Alcatraz"
to, most recently,
"Macbeth" being
performed on Fort Point.
And so Ava will
go ahead and tell
us a little bit
of the background
behind the productions
and what it truly means
and the effect it has
on art in the Bay Area.
And so without further
ado, please join me
in welcoming Ava to Google.
[APPLAUSE]
AVA ROY: Hi.
Thanks for having me, you guys.
So I'm happy, while
I'm here, to give you
a little bit of information
about We Players,
and tell you about
what I do, and give you
some examples of the work.
But I'm really open
to a conversation,
so if you guys have questions
or particular areas of interest
as I'm rattling on, please
feel free to chime in or ask
any questions.
And there's a lot
that I can talk about.
This is my life's
work, so there's
lots of angles and directions.
If there's an area of
particular interest or question,
please chime in,
and we'll kind of
pursue that avenue of things.
But to start us off,
basically, We Players
is, as Cliff just mentioned,
a performing arts company,
and we're dedicated to
site-integrated performance.
And I've actually
sort of shifted
from calling it site-specific
to say "integrated" because I
realize that, as site-specific
is becoming an increasingly
popular term and way
of staging things,
that what I've realized
one of the things that's
really unique about the ways
that We Players create work
is that it's really embedded
in a very particular site.
So each show is non-transferable
to any other site.
It's very carefully
crafted and built
into the physical
environment with awareness
of the sort of historical and
cultural and environmental
energies and factors
of that space.
And I'll give you some
examples to kind of make
a little bit more sense.
But basically, we're
committed and dedicated
to transforming public
spaces into realms
of participatory theater.
So that means that
nowhere is safe
and that everywhere I
go is a potential stage,
a potential performance
environment.
So I'm, hmm, your campus
is pretty interesting.
But one of the things
that's been really special
over the past five
years is that I
started partnering with the
National Park Service in 2008,
and since then I've
been able to develop
this really remarkable
relationship with the National
Park Service.
And we've performed
on Alcatraz Island.
I was the first theater
artist-in-residence on Alcatraz
from 2009 to 2011.
I've been at Fort Point, which
is the Civil War fortress
under the Golden Gate Bridge.
I'll tell you a little
bit more about that.
We have a show there right now.
As well as a five-year
cooperative agreement
with San Francisco Maritime
National Historical
Park, which is, if you
brave Fisherman's Wharf
and get through that, right
after Fisherman's Wharf
and kind of before Ghirardelli
Square, right in that area
is Hyde Street Pier.
And there's these incredible,
old historic ships,
and we perform on
their ships, sometimes
while sailing around the Bay and
sometimes while they're docked.
In addition, we've started
partnering with the California
State Parks as well,
and as Cliff mentioned,
we've done a show
out on Angel Island.
So basically, some of the
main hallmarks of the work
are that, as an audience member,
you're also a participant.
And I'm not interested
in kind of doing
a bunch of crazy things to
get a rise out of people.
I'm the first person, if I go
to a show, and they're like,
we have a volunteer, it's
like, I'm going to just hide.
So it's not that kind
of participation.
It's intended to
create conditions
for certain kinds of experience
so that you sort of drop
into this world of the play.
And the idea is to kind of
create a sphere of performance
so that nothing is outside
of this world of the play.
And so that just
by being there, you
are immersed, quite physically,
into this world of the play,
and that you find yourself
participating kind of
without having to make a
conscious choice about it
necessarily.
Now, the most basic level of
participation that is required
is that you have
to be on your feet,
and you have to physically
move to follow the show
because every scene happens
in a different location
and how the show
moves in the space
is prescribed by the space.
So if it's a huge
island, we're moving
all around the island, up and
down levels, and in and out
of buildings and outdoor spaces.
At the fortress
right now, you're
not covering as
much mileage as you
would be on Alcatraz
or Angel Island,
but you're going up and down
these steep stairways, stone
corridors, the four stories
of the fortress itself.
So you're physically
on your feet,
and you're moving to follow
the show as it moves.
Now, within that, you actually
get to choose and change
your perspective from
which you view the show.
And this is where that more
personal level of participation
and choice and perspective
starts to really drop in
because you can choose to
get really close to an actor
and be really, really
right next to them,
or you can kind of draw back and
kind of get a bigger picture.
If you are briefly distracted
by a flock of birds flying
overhead, or by the full moon
rising behind the warriors
as they battle to their death
on the roof, or the sunset,
or whatever other kind of
miraculous participation
from nature, that's totally
invited and, in fact, very much
part of the work.
Because, while the shows are
very carefully constructed--
and I'm very dedicated to
telling the story of the play
as clearly and as
effectively as I
can-- part of staging
things in these kind
of multi-dimensional
stages, where
we're able to use distance and
proximity to our advantage,
is that you can't possibly catch
everything by seeing it once.
There's just too much going on.
There's too much
detail in the space.
And that my hope is that
in kind of participating
in the theatrical experience
in this way that we become
a little bit more adept at
paying attention to what's
happening above us,
behind us, below us,
and this kind of thing.
And that sometimes those really
special things that happen,
like when a shaft of sunlight
comes in and lights up an actor
for a moment, of course I
can't get that every day.
The light's changing every day.
Temporality is actually a really
big component of the work.
But when that happens,
and you realize,
oh, my gosh, that's
the sun hitting Hamlet,
or whatever it
may be, my hope is
that brings us into a
greater appreciation
that this is a precious,
unrepeatable moment in time,
and it will never happen
this way exactly again.
Which, if we can practice that
in this kind of heightened
container of the
theatrical experience,
we might become a
little bit more facile
at appreciating that in
our day-to-day lives.
So those are kind of some of
the hallmarks of the work,
and I'll talk more
about as we go.
But to give you
some examples, I'm
starting here with
what is easily
recognizable as
"Hamlet," although it
is played by a
woman in this case.
But there's poor Yorick.
And so "Hamlet" was a production
on Alcatraz Island, which
used the entire island.
So the show starts on
the boat, the ferry,
as you're riding over.
And as you can see, the audience
is physically right there next
to Hamlet, and
they're following him
as he is moving
around the island.
In this situation, the
audience is following Hamlet up
a steep incline, and Hamlet
is chasing his father's ghost.
And this is a
representation of the ghost.
So one of the things I was
able to do with this production
is actually, through
this costume choice,
have six different actors
dressed in this way,
and so we were
literally able to create
that effect of the ghost
appearing and disappearing.
Now on the top of the
guard tower 100 feet above
your head, now on
top of the cellhouse,
now in a window, and
then disappearing.
So that as Hamlet's
running up the stairs
and seeing the ghost in
all these different places,
the audience is having that same
experience following Hamlet.
Where is the ghost
going to appear next?
So again, that's kind
of one of the ways
of blowing out the stage space
and having that kind of really
multi-dimensional experience.
This gives you a little bit
of a sense of our backdrops.
Our scenic designer
is quite remarkable.
But of course, you have the Bay
Bridge and San Francisco city
skyline.
And these are some of the
just really precious things
about working in real
spaces that, of course,
you can't achieve in
an indoor theater,
actually having that
relationship to where
you've come from.
You can see where you got
on the boat, San Francisco,
and where you are now.
That's the parade ground
on Alcatraz Island.
These are old rubble
piles from what
used to be large buildings.
Hey, welcome.
So again, this kind of distance
and proximity thing, sometimes
the actors are right up there
with you really close to you
and interacting
directly, so there's
this real immediacy
and real visceral
experience with the actors.
And again, every
scene is kind of
specifically chosen
for different places.
So the show itself is
chosen for the site.
So Alcatraz is not a great place
for "Midsummer Night's Dream,"
but it's a perfect
place for "Hamlet."
But then within
that, after we've
chosen the show for
the space, then there's
the particulars of what scene,
what text, which monologues
happen where, and how can the
space and the story mutually
enhance each other?
So when Hamlet's standing
there on the parade
ground with the
cellhouse behind him
and talking about
"Denmark's a prison,"
and "Oh, I could be
bounded in a nutshell
and count myself a
king of infinite space,
were it not that I
have bad dreams."
He doesn't have to gesture
and gesticulate wildly
to the prison to kind of get
what he means on a deeper level
and on a more visceral level.
So similarly, I'll sort
of use ways of positioning
the audience to inform or affect
how you're receiving the text.
So here, Hamlet's
going through, "Oh,
what a rogue and
peasant slave am I."
And this is where he's feeling
"cabined, cribbed, confined,"
and trying to work out how he's
going to deal with the king,
catching the
conscience of the king.
So we have Hamlet
behind this chain link
fence and the audience
watching the scene through it.
And this is actually an example
of when that shaft of sunlight
came.
And on this one
particular day, it just so
happened the photographer
was there on that day
to catch this moment,
which, again, doesn't happen
all the time, but when it
does it's really precious,
and you suddenly realize
there's a sense of wonder
that I think that we're
trying to achieve in theater.
And when nature can sort of
step in and contribute to that,
it's pretty remarkable
and precious, I think.
Again, here you have a real
closeness of the audience,
and the actors were in the
hospital in the cellhouse here.
And that's been
one of the things
as well, working with the
National Park Service, that's
been really special
is getting access
to the closed areas of the site.
So when you go to Alcatraz
Island, there's a lot of areas
that you actually
can't go into that we
were able to bring
our audiences into.
So you get to have this
really intimate relationship
with the space as well.
And one of the things
that's so precious for me
is actually getting
to see the audience
and getting to see how
it's affecting them.
So they're not somewhere
out in a dark theater,
they're actually right there.
And that is both
wonderful and absolutely
horrible for the actors
because you don't get to hide.
Everything is
really transparent.
Everything is really immediate.
And so if the audience
is totally engaged,
as they are here with
Ophelia after she's just
gone through the sort
of worst breakup ever,
you can see the
empathy on their faces,
and they're really
connected with her.
Of course, if it's
not going well,
and they're like staring off,
then that's also revealed.
So there's this
kind of transparency
that is kind of a
curse and a blessing,
but really unique
for the actors,
and you get to feed off
of the audience in a more
immediate way.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: How do you deal
with the practical stuff
like costume changes?
If everyone's following
Hamlet around all the time,
and he has to change
clothes, where does he go?
AVA ROY: Yeah.
Well, the audience gets to have
a pretty intimate relationship
with the island, but we have an
even more intimate relationship
with these spaces.
We really learn a lot
about all the secret kind
of nooks and crannies.
You would be amazed at what
some of our green rooms
and dressing rooms look like.
I mean, sometimes
they're decent.
But sometimes they are little,
tiny corners of the island,
or a little, like,
an old gardening
shed becomes a quick
costume change location.
And that's actually a big
part of my process as well.
I spend a lot of
time on the site,
long before the actors come.
So even longer before the
audience comes, really
getting to know the space.
And it sounds maybe
a little funny,
but in addition to
kind of learning
about the practical stuff, about
where's our green room going
to be, and where are
the bathrooms, and all
those things, it's also
a lot about a real sort
of intuitive relationship
with the space.
There's a lot of times
where I just go to the site,
and I listen and try to
really listen to the site
and hear what it's saying.
I really believe that
stones hold memories,
and that all the spaces
we inhabit have a history,
and that history is there.
And if we quiet ourselves enough
and slow down enough to tune
in, we might actually hear some
of those echoes of the past.
And that's more obvious
when you go to, like, Greece
or somewhere where there's
really ancient ruins.
And it's somehow more
immediate to feel
that sense of that our
ancestors and ancient people
have walked those
stones, and that's
why the cobblestones in
an old town are smooth.
You can feel that those
feet have walked over it.
Well, that's true even when
it's a little bit harder
to access in some of our
more localized spaces
or our more immediate spaces.
So there's a lot of spending
time in the space checking out,
what does the light do at
different times of day?
What's the weather like?
What are the natural
traffic patterns?
What are the birds doing?
What is the time of year are
we going to be in the space?
What phase is the moon in?
And letting all of those things,
both on a practical level
in terms of rain and wind
and those kinds of concerns,
as well as on an
energetic level.
Both work to kind of support
how the show works in the space.
And here you can see
the audience kind
of backing up Hamlet and Horatio
as they walk to the [INAUDIBLE]
for the final battle with
the city behind them.
And the final view of the
show, where you actually
get a sense of the relationship
of some of these photos
I've showed you to where the
cellhouse and the lighthouse
is itself.
So from Alcatraz-- we
did that show in 2010.
We actually had a
three-year residency,
so there was a couple
of other projects
we did out there as well, but
"Hamlet" happened in 2010.
And then we went over
to Hyde Street Pier.
This is Alice Watts, who's
the first mate of the schooner
"Alma." "Alma" is a
150-year-old scow schooner.
She's the only boat in
the SF Maritime Fleet
that actually still sails.
This is actually from the
stern of the "Balclutha," which
is another boat at
Hyde Street Pier.
Those are the actors
up on the stern,
or what's called the poop
deck of the "Balclutha."
She's a three-masted
tall ship who's
actually sailed around
the horn 17 times, which
is kind of cool in terms
of that relationship
to history and the past.
This is before engines.
This is before there
was a Panama Canal.
So it's pretty amazing
to step foot on that boat
and feel that she
has this history,
and that we get to play and
uncover some of her stories
through telling these stories.
So back to "Alma."
This is the Cyclops
eating Barbies
on the stern of the
"Alma" while sailing.
So this show was a production
of the "Odyssey" that took place
on "Alma," so she was a
60-foot floating stage.
Something that's
cool about a scow
is they're a flat-bottomed boat.
They were the original barges.
So these were sailing barges
that would move hay and produce
back and forth from the San
Francisco Bay to the delta
and back and forth, and
so she doesn't heel.
So for an audience, it's
basically like a floating stage
because you don't have the
classic sailboat bottom,
and so we don't
heel side to side.
It's like a raft with sails.
So it's a really stable
vessel for a show.
And here we are sailing past
our previous stage, Alcatraz.
And that's been one
of the things that's
been pretty cool over
the past few years
is now looking out on
the San Francisco Bay
and seeing all of these
stages and all of these places
that have been transformed.
And that's one of my
favorite pieces of feedback
from audience members
is that they say,
Alcatraz is now Denmark forever.
Angel Island is now
Greece and Ithaca
and the home of Odysseus's
trials and tribulations.
So these spaces are
transformed, and that's
something so special
about theater, right?
It's this ephemeral thing.
It's birth as a death.
It happens, and we let
it go, and it evaporates.
And it's, as I
was saying before,
this kind of precious
and unrepeatable moment
that flies away,
but it can live on,
when it's really
effective, in the hearts
and minds and psyches of the
people who experienced it.
And so that's one of the things
that's really rewarding well
after the fact, when
people come and they
say that these sites
have been transformed.
And furthermore, that we've been
able to expose a lot of people
to these really incredible
gems of our local landscape
that people didn't know about.
A lot of people don't know
that Hyde Street Pier exists.
They don't want to go down
to Fisherman's Wharf because
of the dense tourist experience.
But if you just brave
it a little bit further,
you find this incredible park
and these incredible boats.
And you can see kind of
closeness to the actors,
so it's really happening in
front of you, around you,
amongst you, and so forth,
as well as above you.
Here we commissioned
some artists
to paint giant
backdrops on sails.
So we have this kind of
10-foot eye painted on a sail
to help us tell the
story of the Cyclops.
And we also were able to send
Hermes up aloft on the mast,
so he's about 80
feet above your head
on the top of the rig
as the god Hermes.
And then from the
stern of "Alma,"
you can look out and
see Angel Island,
which was our next stage.
So we continued with this
theme of the "Odyssey"
for a couple of years, and
then took the "Odyssey"
to Angel Island.
So while it was first a show
on a 60-foot floating stage,
we then blew that out
to a five-hour show
that encompassed a
five-mile perimeter out
around an 800-acre stage,
which was Angel Island.
So here is Telemachus,
Odysseus's son,
waiting at the
beach in Ayala Cove
as the ferry full of
audience members arrive.
And as soon as you arrive,
part of the idea, again, as I
was talking about before,
that the sphere of performance
is that we try to create an
experience where you feel
like the world exists
with or without you.
And so you get to participate
for a time, and in this case,
when you arrive as audience
members from the ferry,
you step right into Ithaca.
And the suitors are
playing games, and jeering,
and drinking, and partying,
and barbecuing meat,
and you're sort of
brought right into it
and encouraged to play
tug of war with them
or eat from the
barbecue or drink.
And so there's this
whole world kind
of already happening that
you get to step into.
Again, you get a sense
of distance as well.
So we're close
Telemachus in this scene,
but Mentor is appearing up
on the hillside behind him.
This photo doesn't capture
it, but even behind him,
even farther up the hill,
is Athena overlooking.
So again, you get
to kind of really
challenge your own perspective
in terms of looking both
what's in the foreground as
well as what's in the distance.
And here's the intrepid
audience trekking along
after Telemachus.
And it's a long journey,
and it was certainly
part of the intention to send
the audience on an odyssey
themselves.
And it would sort of crack me
up when people after the show
would say, but I'm still
hungry, and I'm so tired.
It's, like, yeah, yeah.
Good work.
You are.
You should be.
It was five hours of hard work.
So we went to many different
worlds on Angel Island.
With an 800-acre
stage, you can imagine
that there's many different
environments within that.
So on the windward side of
the island, where we are now,
there's lots of
wind, and you have
the view of the
Golden Gate Bridge.
And so that was a good
setting for Aeolia.
Aeolus was the king of the wind.
So this is where we went
for the king of the wind
and used the wind
as much as possible,
so using lots of
fabrics and kites
and things that embrace
the wind in that land.
And you can see the
Golden Gate Bridge,
which, again, is a kind of
incredible scenic backdrop
that you don't get
in an indoor space.
And some days there
would be regattas,
and there would be sailboats
going by and pretty fun stuff.
And again, you can kind of
see Alcatraz behind Telemachus
and the city behind him.
So this awareness of just
expanding our relationship
to how we relate to the
spaces that we inhabit
and the spaces that we live in.
So as we're moving
around the island,
as you curve around the
west side of the island
and start heading east a little
bit, you get to the old quarry.
And actually, this quarry,
a lot of the stone that
was quarried there
is at the foundation
of the financial district
in San Francisco and also
became Mount Olympus, which
has kind of a nice metaphor,
but more importantly,
it's an 80-foot cliff.
And that created
a really nice way
to actually have that feeling
of looking up at the gods
and then being truly
towering over you.
So the gods were up there.
You can imagine it in rehearsal.
This is kind of
hilarious in terms
of directing because you're
yelling up to your actors, OK,
more like this.
Move to the left.
Hike up that hill, come back
down, get notes, hike back up.
And I'm focusing, of
course, on the joys
of how nature contributes.
Often there was an eagle
that-- not an eagle, a hawk,
a red-tailed hawk that
nests nearby the quarry that
would often fly right over
Zeus's head during the scene.
I mean, it's just
an amazing thing.
Especially for people who
know a little bit more
about Greek mythology, you
know Zeus's relationship
to eagles and birds of prey.
Some of the not-so-awesome
things that happen sometimes
when nature contributes
is there was also
a family of geese that decided
to nest on the hillside.
And that became really
borderline for a while
there, because if those
eggs were to hatch,
we would not be able to use
Mount Olympus as Mount Olympus.
And there was, obviously,
no other choice for that.
So while it's fun to focus on
all of the really positive ways
that nature contributes, and
for the most part, that's
my experience, there's
certainly some things.
When a helicopter goes overhead
at exactly the wrong moment,
and you're in this
really deep soliloquy,
and you either have to wait
for it or shout over it.
But in any medium, whether
it's art or otherwise,
there's constraints
and affordances,
and you work within that.
So for me, a lot of the
affordances and blessings
of the environment far
outweigh the constraints,
even though there
were a lot of ticks
at the bottom of Mount
Olympus and things like that.
That's not so great.
So after rehearsal
in Mount Olympus,
everyone's doing
their tick check.
So it's a pretty
unique kind of actor
as well for whom this is
a good fit because it's
certainly very
demanding physically.
There's a lot of old
batteries on Angel Island.
Angel Island actually
has 130 years
of military history, which
is kind of rather unknown.
A lot of people focus
on the immigration story
on Angel Island, which is
a really important part
of the island's history.
But there's also a huge and
longstanding military history,
and so there's
these old batteries
from World War I
and World War II.
This was the Cyclops'
cave, and the audience
was locked inside this dark
cave and needed to escape.
And actually, when
you step outside--
I don't have a
photo of this here--
but when you step outside,
we felled a eucalyptus tree,
which are non-native,
and so they're
trying to thin them out
on Angel Island anyway,
so we played our part.
But we felled a eucalyptus
tree and shaved the end of it
down to a spike, and
it's covered in blood.
So when you actually step
out of the Cyclops' cave,
if you know the
story, you realize
that this is the
stake that Odysseus
has used to poke out
the Cyclops' eye.
And something that's cool is,
if you don't get the story,
you're not left out.
What actually happens
is that when you're
walking from site to site,
you start to overhear--
and I'm often sort of incognito
in the audience tuning
in to this-- and you
start to overhear
people talking to each other,
and people explaining it.
And one of the most
remarkable things
is that little kids are some
of the best interpreters
because they're
totally able to engage.
They're not sitting in a seat.
Well, none of us are, but
we're moving and moving around.
So the kids really get to
run and follow the actors
and get up really close.
And because of the Percy Jackson
and "The Lightning Thief"
phenomenon, they know the
"Odyssey" really well.
So it was amazing to be walking
on the trail between scenes
and hear people
talking to each other
and asking each other questions,
audience members who maybe
didn't come together and
maybe didn't know each other,
and then little kids chiming
in and giving more information
about, no, no, no, that was
Circe and that's Calypso.
So that's pretty
special, that parents
get to bring their kids.
And it's not a
kid's show, but both
get to really experience
it in a full way.
There's also some
audience participation.
I focused on just the moving
and following the shows.
There's some situations where
you can choose your path,
and you can only choose
one, like in life.
So here we meet
at the crossroads,
and Zeus meets you
there, and says,
you can go one of
three directions.
You can go to the
island of Temenos,
where sacred beauties
will anoint to you
and sing to you and
soothing and whatnot.
It was secretly
the best way to go.
But most people felt
like they needed
to prove their mettle in
the obstacle course, which
was held on the Nike
Missile launching site.
So that's a Cold War site with
subterranean missile silos,
and we transformed that into the
land of Scylla and Charybdis,
two of the most fearsome,
loathsome creatures
known to mortals.
And the third option
was to climb up a hill,
hike up a little hill, and cheer
on the hero of your choice.
So here, Zeus gives
you that choice,
and you can either
run, literally run,
to the obstacle course.
You can hike up the
hill and watch it.
Or you can follow the
bard, [INAUDIBLE],
who will sing to you as
you go to the chapel.
So you have these options.
Here's Zeus up on
the hill with those
who chose to watch
the obstacle course.
And these are tentacles
of Scylla coming up
from the silos, and the audience
braving their way through.
At some points, you
meet Hermes on the path.
He often is on various golden
things, golden scooters,
golden bicycles,
golden transport.
And this is the
island of Temenos.
And I want to pause
here just briefly
because, while only less than a
third of the overall audiences
actually got to see this
scene, this location was
a place that some things
happened that really reminded
me and gave me so
much fuel and juice
for why put in all
the work to do this.
I'm really interested in
ritual, and that performance
is born out of ritual,
the first storytellers who
were gathering around
fires and telling stories.
And so I'm really
interested in what
ritual can teach us to make our
modern-day performances more
than entertainment and something
really sacred and really
special, or at least create
the possibility for that.
And that happened on
a number of occasions,
where there were no
words in the scene.
There were three women dressed
all in white in an old chapel,
in a World War II-era
chapel, and they
were singing
beautiful harmonies.
And you came in,
and they just sang.
They didn't speak.
But you would walk in and every
traveler, every weary traveler,
they'd bring in.
You were like three hours
into this five-hour ride
at this point, so you
are tired and hot.
And they bring you in,
and they wash your hands
with eucalyptus-scented water.
And they walk around, and
they dip flowers in cold water
and touch it to your forehead.
And really, really
simple gestures
that have no
religious connotation,
but I saw so many people
walk up and receive it
as if they were receiving
communion, I mean,
actually bow to these women
with tears in their eyes.
And when the women
would come around
with these little flowers, they
were like flowers to the light,
like, don't forget
me, don't forget me.
And for me, that was a
really precious reminder
of what can happen.
That there was a kind
of spiritual energy
and a kind of real
communion with the actors
and with the environment
and with what happened.
And this, again, was
without any words
and without any telling you
how to feel and without, again,
any religious connotation,
but some really special energy
was shared in that space.
So it reminded me that
that's, in addition
to being really grand
and glorious and fun,
that it can also be
really sublime as well.
You travel to Circe's house.
I'll move fairly
quickly through these.
We went to the
House of the Dead,
which is a stage in
an old hospital, kind
of burned-out skeleton
of a building.
The dead emerge on four
floors above your heads.
We go down to a
beach where Calypso
is and wants to
keep you forever.
And Hermes appears on
his latest golden ride,
his golden speedboat.
So again, this is
one of those things,
you know, you're four
and a half hours in,
and your back is to the water,
and you're facing Calypso.
And you think, this
is pretty nice.
All these beautiful
women who just want to,
like, massage my hands and
take care of me forever.
And the next thing you
know, from behind you,
you hear this sound of
trumpets, and you turn around,
and there's Hermes
and his entourage.
So besides using
levels, in this case
we also got to use the water
in the distance behind you.
Here's Hermes showing off.
That Hermes.
And we leave Angel Island, and
we move to Hyde Street Pier.
This is Hyde Street
Pier, which I've
talked a little
bit about already.
This is a hysterical
shipwrecked woman in a rowboat.
So this is "Twelfth
Night," which
starts out with a shipwreck.
And so the audience
actually met on the beach
and didn't really
know it was going
to happen until
they started hearing
these wailing sobs of a woman
on a rowboat, who then jumps out
of the water and runs
up onto the beach.
And we actually
got a lot of people
who would call in
and say, there's
a hysterical woman on the beach.
What's going on?
And luckily, all of
our park partners
were able to pretty quickly
translate that, no, it's OK.
And then from there, the
show moves down the pier,
and we use all of the
different boats in this case.
So you can see
the audience close
to the actors on the
pier, the audience,
actually, on the other side of
the pier watching from a boat.
So we're just trying
to use as much
of the full and total
environment as possible.
Again, proximity
with the audience.
It's pretty fun to
get these moments
of people's appreciation.
This woman's feeling pretty
tickled about being right
next to that actor, and
of course, Malvolio.
If we have time later, I'll
show you some video of the show.
But I'd like to move on
just so that I can tell you
a little bit about "Macbeth,"
which is the current show.
So we're three
weeks into the run.
We have three weeks left,
Thursday through Sunday,
"Macbeth at Fort Point."
And this is the fortress.
So when you step
inside, this is a sense
of what it's like inside with
the Golden Gate Bridge soaring
overhead and the
three sisters working
their charms on the heath.
And one of the things that's
really amazing at Fort Point,
and there are so many
things, and in fact,
in all of these shows, that the
natural sonic landscape really
informs your experience.
So here at Fort Point, you
have the crashing of the waves
up against the
fortress walls, which
is sort of mirrored by the
sound of the rumbling traffic
over your head.
And on foggy days, every
five seconds or so,
you get this deep, low
base note of the foghorn.
So our music director
is really trying
to incorporate these
sounds into and embrace
what's already there.
So we're not trying
to push that away.
We're saying, yes, this
is what the space is like.
That's why it's
perfect for "Macbeth,"
and how can we have our
work kind of merge with that
rather than push against it?
The fortress, this is kind
of within the interior space.
So sometimes you're on the
open heath in the middle.
Sometimes you're
moving in and out
of these kind of dark
corridors and so forth.
And it's pretty incredible
as you're walking around.
I mean, at first, you're just
like, OK, seven million bricks.
And then you get
in close, and you
realize there are vibrant
lichens of all different colors
growing on the walls, and
there's all these patinas
that you would spend a lifetime
in a stage shop creating
that are just natural
because it's so old.
Again, it gives
you a little sense
of the scale of the space.
And as an audience,
you're moving up and down
all the levels of the space.
The three sisters are kind
of omnipresent in a way.
They also act as the
servants, and so they
can be anywhere and
everywhere, so they're
sort of watching and observing.
And they are the ways
that the walls have ears,
so they're gathering
all of this information
throughout the show.
There's poor, dead Bankwell.
And here as well, there's
two different groups.
Sometimes you're moving
all as one group.
Sometimes you're splitting
into multiple groups
and seeing things in
a different order.
Sometimes you're seeing things
from different vantage points.
So every site kind
of has its own way
of informing how
we move through.
With Angel Island, it
was fairly processional,
one route all the way around.
With other sites
like Fort Point,
because some of the areas
are so confined and narrow,
and you can only fit
so many people in them,
we'll break you up and
have you see things
in different order and
different vantages.
And sometimes you actually
get to go indoors,
which is a rare treat, and
encounter strange and sort
of inverted domestic tasks
that the witches are up to.
Again, just another
sense of the scale
of the space, interior space,
and the poor, dead Macduff.
And then, one of the things
that's really fun about this
show-- I don't know if fun is
the right word for "Macbeth"--
but that we start in
the daylight, and that,
as the play descends into deeper
and deeper darkness of psyche
and soul, the light
descends as well.
And I mentioned very briefly
earlier about temporality
and how season and time
plays a big role in this.
So that's the
durational experience
of the "Odyssey," being
on a five-hour ride
and feeling tired and hungry and
getting cranky at some point,
and then getting
your second wind,
and that aspect of temporality.
But certainly also relationship
to natural daylight
and the change of light and how
that can work with the show.
And here you have the
audience participating
as Birnam Wood is
storming the castle.
Hi.
So that gives you
just a little bit
of a sense of some of the
ways that we use space.
And again, that
every single site
has its own constraints
and affordances and stories
and energies and
can really inform
how we use the space,
how we move through it.
As much as possible trying to
have the sound and the costumes
all really feel like
they belong to the space,
and they come from the
space, rather than something
where we're bringing onto it.
Yeah.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Can you talk
about the evolution
of this entire concept
from a personal standpoint?
AVA ROY: Sure.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: How did
you come to do this--
murder mystery
theater or, you know--
AVA ROY: No, I went to Stanford.
That's how it happened.
What does that mean?
Yeah.
So I went to Stanford,
and I grew up
in a very small town in
Western Massachusetts.
But that small town has a
company called Shakespeare
and Company, so I grew
up studying Shakespeare
and performing in lots
of Shakespeare shows
since I was, like, 12 or 13.
So I had a real passion
for Shakespeare.
But then when I
got to Stanford--
I had never visited the campus.
And honestly, I
just felt at a loss.
I felt like I was on this
really, really beautiful
country club that I didn't
know how to relate to.
And so, honestly,
starting this company
was a way of building a personal
relationship with that space.
When I shifted from feeling
like I didn't belong to oh,
this is my playground.
And what happens if I tie
banners to the clock tower
and have people use these
incredible stairways
and sculptures as the backdrop?
So the shift for me, and that's
been a shift that started there
that's been fundamental in
the way that I see the world,
is what happens if
we invite ourselves
to be citizens of the world?
And that everywhere
we go, we allow
ourselves to say, how
do I have a relationship
to this environment?
What does that mean for me?
And so, it really started
as a very personal practice
of wanting to marry my passion
for Shakespeare with finding
a way to kind of
belong to the space.
And then I found that
as I started to do that,
it became very
much an experiment,
a social experiment, of
what would people do?
If Romeo and Juliet
are getting married
in the middle of
the quad, and you
have to either walk through it
or avoid it to get to class,
what would people do?
And so asking that as a question
has just immediately, I mean,
immediately provided so many
amazing encounters and moments
of beauty and
surprise, where people
would drop what they were doing
and join the parade because it
was so precious and so unique.
And so I feel like that really
inspired me to just keep
asking these questions
and keep asking, what if?
What's right outside-- what's
right around the corner
of our imagination?
What might happen here?
What has happened here?
What could happen here?
So it's very much an
open-ended question
and a way of relating to space.
And again, doing these shows
throughout the Bay Area,
it's a big part of
my mission to try
to get people to
connect with these gems
of our local
landscape, of places
that we drive over the
Golden Gate Bridge,
or we pass by, we pass
through, rather than pausing
in for a time and actually
kind of checking it out
and being with it.
So I think we can kind of
practice that all the time.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: How do you deal with
the acoustics in the spaces
that you work?
AVA ROY: How do I deal
with the acoustics?
The acoustics are
really challenging.
One thing is working with
actors who are really
practiced at breathing
from their bellies.
So in life, this
is useful as well.
When you speak from
your throat, you
tend to blow your voice out.
And when you speak from a
deep, supported belly breath,
you can project much further.
So part of it's training
and chops and experience,
and part of it is just
straight up challenging.
I mean, when you
come to Fort Point,
it's likely that you won't catch
every single word because when
the wind comes up
and is fierce, you
have to be aware, as an actor,
of where the wind is coming
from and let the wind carry your
voice in the right direction
rather than the
opposite direction.
But as I was
mentioning earlier, it
is one of the constraints of the
spaces, of working in this way,
is that sound can
really be an issue.
But I'm so interested in the
living word and the living body
that I really try to avoid
technology as much as possible.
We use it when we
need to and when
it will support and
make it possible.
So at Fort Point,
we're using lights
because the show
happens at night,
and it's great to embrace that.
But as much as possible, I want
to work with natural elements,
including the natural
instrument of the voice.
But it's challenging, for sure.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Do you start with
the show [INAUDIBLE] location?
AVA ROY: That's a
really good question,
and it's a difficult one to
answer because it's both,
I guess.
That sometimes I have
a long list of shows
I'm interested in,
and then, as I'm just
exploring and
scouting, sites will
emerge that seem like
a really good fit.
And sometimes that first hit
is like, boom, this is it.
"Hamlet on Alcatraz" done.
Like, there's no other
choice, you know?
And sometimes it's
like, well, OK,
that seems like a good lead.
But let me sniff
it out for a while,
and spend some
time in that space,
and read the story
while I'm in the space,
and ask more questions,
and do some research,
and see if it's
really a good fit.
Sometimes I get
that initial hit,
and then I go and look at
half a dozen other spaces
only to come back
to the first one.
And a lot of times,
I go to a space,
and it's the space
that informs the story.
I go, and I
investigate the site.
And then, through that
being in the place
and listening to the place
and doing some research,
the story will emerge.
So it's kind of
a dance, and it's
a little different
with every location.
Yeah.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: How much
of the audience
knows what they're
getting in to?
AVA ROY: That's a
good question, too.
How much of the audience knows?
Well, you get a fairly
lengthy confirmation email
when you reserve for We Players
because it's kind of like, this
is how you need to prepare for
your journey, really, really.
So when you come to the
"Odyssey on Angel Island,"
it's like, bring water, bring
snacks, wear closed-toed shoes,
bring sunscreen, wear
hats, and we mean it.
Whereas Fort Point,
forget all that stuff.
You need your winter parkas.
You need hats, scarves, gloves,
and maybe a flask of whisky.
No, don't say I said that.
So there's lots of
different ways of preparing.
So you do get a
fairly lengthy email.
It's still amazing to me,
even though we have it
on the website, and we send an
email, and we send a reminder.
And at the reservation, we say,
do you have something warmer?
Because that's a cute
dress, but I think
you're really going to
want a warmer layer.
But there's still people who
show up in the wrong gear,
and they learn pretty quickly.
But we do really try to
help the audience prepare.
That said, it's also
an acquired skill
coming to a We
Players performance.
You can really tell the veteran
audiences from the new people
because they know that when
they hear the music-- music is
huge in moving the audience.
The pied piper phenomenon
is a real thing.
People will move
without instruction
to wherever the
sound is coming from
or where the
musicians are moving.
And so veteran We Players
audience members hear
that music, and they're moving.
They're there.
They know that you can
get up right up close
and kneel down and be
really close to the actors.
Where other people kind
of take a little time
to figure out what's OK.
And it's really
great because we've
been doing this for long
enough that we always
have some of those
more seasoned audience
members in the crowd
who really help create
the culture and the
vibe of the audience.
You know, I was talking before
about how for the actors
it's totally transparent, this
relationship to the audience.
But that's something pretty
unique about the audience
as well is that you're
next to each other.
You're not pretending the
person next to you isn't there.
You're negotiating
with each other.
So in a way, it is kind of
this heightened sort of version
of being in the
world, where you have
to negotiate with the
people around you.
If someone's taller than you,
and they're in front of you,
how do you deal?
Are you proactive, and
you get in front of them
and kneel down?
Do you reposition yourself?
So there's these kind of
like little interesting
social questions
and experiments that
are happening within dropping
into this world of the play
and following the story.
CLIFF: So I think one final
question before we head off.
So you use a lot
of the same cast.
There's a lot of veterans
that come through,
and you don the actor's mantle
from time to time as well.
So how do you approach that
in terms of, like, recruiting
people and training folks
to your style of theater,
and what's it like to
perform in your own shows?
AVA ROY: Yeah.
Well, it's really been
interesting in the past.
When I started
this, I was 18, 19.
And so I was directing, and
producing, and stage managing,
and making all the clothes,
and et cetera, et cetera,
et cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
And so over time, as
things have evolved,
I've obviously, like
most growing startups,
have tried to delegate
and share and step out
of some of those roles so that
I can do the things that I
am doing more fully.
So to that end, I
sort of stepped away
from being in the shows until
recently, where one of my,
actually, oldest teachers, who
I've known since I was like 11,
has become a really close
collaborator of mine.
And so when I have a co-director
and assistant director who
I can really trust, then I
feel like I can be in the show.
So I actually play Lady Macbeth
in the current production,
and that's thanks to
having a co-director
who's really incredible
and who I work well with.
And so it's been really a treat
to be able to kind of stretch
my acting muscles again,
thanks to having an outside eye
that I can trust.
As far as the actors,
there are kind
of repeat offenders,
people who I've
worked with for a few years
and continue to work with.
I audition every year, so I'm
always looking for new people.
And my auditions are like a
three or four-hour workshop
experience, so that
alone helps to sift out
the people who are the right
fit because you don't get
to come in and do a five-minute
monologue and go away.
You have to really commit to
being there for some time.
And for me, that's
both a way of getting
to know not just how well do
you audition, but how are you?
How do you play?
How do you listen?
How do you work?
Because that's what
we're really getting into
is months of working together,
and that's really important.
And vice versa, I feel like
it's important for actors
not to just have the director
kind of being all-knowing,
standing behind the
table judging you,
but actually, how do I work?
Do you vibe with how I work?
Is this going to be
a mutually-beneficial
collaboration?
So that's a big part of how the
audition process and a longer,
more durational
audition process,
for me, helps sift
out people who
are a good fit for
this type of work.
And also, holding auditions
for specific shows
in the site they're
going to be in.
Because if you can't get to
Angel Island for an audition,
it's probably not going
to work out great for you
to be there every weekend
for six months or something
like that.
So for some people
that I've found
that I've been working
with, they really
are just so invigorated
by being in these spaces
and being outdoors.
And it's just not for
everybody, and that's great.
It's better to know that and
say, no, I'd rather actually
be in an indoor space with a
more controlled environment.
So part of it is having
really honest communication
with the people I'm working
with, auditioning in the space,
doing more durational,
physically-intensive work.
Because there is kind of
like an actor-athlete thing
going on, where you have to
hike and climb and be excited
and turned on by that, not
just willing to survive it.
And I find that for people
who are really into it,
the elemental forces
actually become
a source of incredible power.
So when we first started
working at Fort Point,
it's easy to feel really
overwhelmed by how windy
and how cold it is.
And for some
people, there starts
to be a shift of
like, actually, I'm
going to use this
wind and this cold
to empower me rather than feel
totally overwhelmed by it.
So asking those questions
and paying attention
to how people
respond to the space
is a big part of
selecting the tribe.
AUDIENCE: Non-Equity?
AVA ROY: For the
most part, yeah.
It's actually a very
difficult thing,
because with Equity
rules, the rules
aren't made for this
type of theater.
So in Equity, it's like you
can't carry your own props.
Like, well, but if you
have to go two miles
to get to your next scene,
you might need to carry your--
so it's an interesting
conundrum for sure.
CLIFF: All right.
Well, Ava, thank you very much
for speaking with us today.
And we look forward to more
amazing shows in the Bay Area.
AVA ROY: Thank you.
CLIFF: So thank you very much.
AVA ROY: Thanks, you guys.
Thanks for having me.
[APPLAUSE]